I don't know much about fashion but I'm
kind of fascinated by it and I I'm just
curious
are there any trends out there today
that you're not down with for example
you know like the the real low-slung
jeans were a thing for the ladies for a
while the really low riding jean where
you see the little V that's not cute
that's not good no club rap okay
that's Tiger what what desperate
desperate oh desperate hungry tiger
horny oh I think these were brand names
for jeans I want little V that's creepy
but then the guys just edit all this the
men started wearing the jeans that are
like I honestly there's someone who buys
me the suits for the show and one day he
said oh I got you some jeans he like got
me some jeans and I put him on and they
like started down here and I'm like I
can't do that I never really noticed but
Joel who's my husband he still sags and
he is in his 30s and I never really had
a problem with it until he bent over one
time and I saw all of his underwear and
I was like honey like that you just you
just took your father yeah you're a
father and and you're in your 30s and so
those days are days are long gone right
but you know I mean that's his thing and
I'm I'm fine with that I think sagging
is kind of hot I can't I would like
sagging because I have no ass and it
creates the look like will you have a
real saggy jeans you don't know what's
what's going on back there you don't I
mean I think you have to have a little
bunk to hold it I'm very confusing
because I've never done it but I think
you maybe have to have a little cushion
to keep the jeans there no no what I
would do is I would get a surgical
staple at the base that holds the gene
and then I would put stuff back there
alarm clocks smart very smart
pillows anything to fill it out plants
yeah just anything I could do I have a
lot of great ideas you should talk to me
okay it's really your career fashion
start you having a good time I am I am
it's a it's a it's a wonderful show and
it's such a great opportunity and you
know the the the the idea is very
complex but you know now that we are
getting down to the wire and you know
just really focusing on these last
designers you're really getting to know
them and then looking at their struggle
and you know just really going with them
through this journey so it's very what I
like is I like an any night but about
this I like reality shows where you need
to know something well you know these
competition shows where people need to
have a skill and are and they're
artistic and they need to demonstrate
what it is they're good at yeah you know
these these designers they really are
artists you know they've been working at
this their entire lives and this
opportunity is just amazing and then
it's of course fun for the audience to
watch because as you're watching the
clothes go down the runway you're able
to buy them online that night or go into
the stores the very next day and buy
them so you know this is it's it's it's
a it's a genius idea